außerhalb der korona regeln beschäftigt
unsere gesellschaft ja auch sehr der
tank rabatt und
thorsten frei weg gebracht ja sehr gerne
beim tank rabatt geht es letztlich darum
dass wir seit geraumer zeit seit dem
vergangenen jahr mit einer ganz
erheblichen inflation konfrontiert sind
das macht sich nicht nur bei den
energiepreisen bemerkbar auch bei den
lebensmittel kosten und andere mehr und
die muss man grundsätzlich und
gesamthaft begegnen aber insbesondere
muss man diejenigen die besonders
geschlagen sind von dieser preis
explosion eben auch ganz praktisch
helfen
und wenn ich mir die zwei energie
entlastungs paket der bundesregierung
anschaue dann stelle ich fest dass da
zum einen ganz offensichtlich mit der
schrotflinte geschossen wird das heißt
nicht sehr ziel und treff genau und auf
der anderen seite eben auch nicht die
wirklich entlastet werden dies benötigen
ich finde nicht dass nur die menschen im
ländlichen raum entlastet werden müssten
was den tank rabatt anbelangt aber die
haben eben besonders große
schwierigkeiten auf alternativen
zurückzugreifen wenn sie zur arbeit
fahren müssen wenn sie zum arzt in den
verein für die kinder fahren müssen oder
anderes mehr und deswegen geht es
einfach darum schnell zu entlasten da
gibt es wichtige bestandteile wie
beispielsweise die senkung der energie
steuer das ist sehr effektiv das haben
wir auch als unions fraktion
vorgeschlagen wir hätten uns darüber
hinaus auch eine absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer auf kraftstoffe
vorstellen können aber es gibt eben auch
andere dinge die da nicht zielgenau sind
die bundesregierung gibt 2,5 millionen
euro milliarden euro aus für das neuen
euro ticket ohne dass es dafür
zusätzliches wagenmaterial gibt ohne
dass man vorbereitet wird auf die
zusätzlichen nutzer und es scheint auch
ein strohfeuer zu bleiben weil es ab
august der eine solche lösung nicht mehr
geben wird ich befürchte dass das den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr in
deutschland nicht attraktiver macht und
vor allen dingen muss man sehen im
bereich der nahverkehrs preise gab es
keine steigerung in den vergangenen
wochen also das scheint eher ein pulli
typisches projekt zu sein als dass es
tatsächlich um die entlastung für
menschen wir haben ja hier jemanden der
auch in der regierung ist die partei die
grünen herr jentzsch etwas ist da los
mit dem tank rabatt und mit dem neuen
euro ticket und was machen sie für den
job wenn ich hier freya suhre
also ich will jetzt nicht verhehlen dass
ich kein fan des tank rabatt zwar das
habe ich auch öffentlich gesagt das war
ist übrigens auch er frei und junioren
weil ich das wirklich öffentlich
deswegen noch mal sagen ich aber
aufpassen sonst geht es ihm bei die
japaner nun anscheinend in ihrer partei
nicht zu sehr geklappt da bin ich in dem
fall jetzt auch nicht zu denen die da
das gibt nicht so viele die das
begeistert so finden glaube ich wir
müssen ja auch kompromisse machen das
auch okay und deswegen haben wir den
kompromiss gemacht zu sagen wenn schon
auf der einen seite wie den spritpreis
subventionieren was sich weder als
ökologe noch als marktwirtschaftler gut
finde dann wenigstens auch ein signal
setzen für die menschen die den
öffentlichen nahverkehr nutzen sie haben
stück weit recht in berlin und münchen
könnte das zu problemen führen weil wir
zu einer überlastung kommen aber also in
mittelstädten ländlichen regionen kann
das jetzt schon für drei monate auch mal
ein anreiz bieten zu sagen ich nutze
jetzt mal bei immer noch hohen preisen
wir wissen ja gar nicht ob die
tankstellenbetreiber insbesondere
ölkonzerne die preise gut weitergeben
also kartellamt bis jetzt aufgefordert
worden heute ja auch von ihnen zu sagen
da müssen wir mal hingucken zeigt auch
wieder dass das wirklich ein schwieriges
instrument ist dass der staat sozusagen
an dem vw fahrer den spritpreis ist
garantiert für drei monate das ist jetzt
so gemacht als entlastung und deswegen
ja entlastung es notwendig inflation ist
hoch aber die instrumente sind auf jeden
fall drei monate begrenzten dass wir
nicht auch gut dass die drei monate
begrenzt sind danach müssen wir auch
klarkommen ich habe ein problem mit dem
begriff subventionierung also es geht
darum dass man eine besteuerung auf
kraftstoffe absenkt das ist ja für sich
genommen keine subventionierung sondern
wenn man sich den spritpreis anguckt
egal ob für super oder diesel dann
stellt man eben fest dass über
öffentliche abgaben und steuern ein
großteil der kosten entstehen und
deswegen finde ich das durchaus normal
ich habe vorhin ja gesagt ich hätte mir
auch eine temporäre absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer auf kraftstoffe
vorstellen können weil die stark
gestiegenen preise ja auch dazu führen
dass der staat in diesem bereich
erhebliche mehreinnahmen hat im dezember
im januar haben wir schon gesehen wie
die mehr werth steuereinnahmen für den
staat erheblich gestiegen sind und wenn
man so will sind des windfall profits
für den start wo man durchaus sagen kann
das ist geld das kann man auch wieder
zurückgeben zur entlastung der menschen
und man kann es zielgerichtet tun damit
diejenigen die besonders belastet sind
davon eben auch besonders deswegen sagen
wir das dann klima geld her muss um das
klima geld geht an alle wird der zucker
diskutiert soll das sozial gestaffelt
sein anliegen war das ist doch wieder so
eine umschichtung und das ist da kann
man aber als individuum handeln und so
will ich das so sagen darf ist es jetzt
so dass wir sagen sprit preissenkungen
für drei monate wir wissen nicht ob es
100 prozent weitergegeben wird sie haben
recht windfall profits geht man nicht
über über gewinne dran machen andere
staaten also sehr sehr komplex und am
ende wollen wir eigentlich dass nicht
mehr geld nach russland geht ja und
geben jetzt endlich geld dafür dass die
leute beim autofahren in diktator aus
werden sie kaufen jetzt quasi bei
anderen das ist eine andere diskussion
hat sich schon als tanken und b gehört
dazu und die lösungsvorschläge der
politik aber denkt man nicht auch
manchmal es muss doch irgendwie
einfacher gehen
grundsätzlich finde ich schön wenn wir
sozusagen den bürger die kosten für die
bürger geht gerade die energiekosten
senken das was im moment passiert nicht
nur bei den spritpreisen sondern alle
energiepreise sind ja massiv gestiegen
in den letzten jahren und gerade für
familien die die können eigentlich von
den energiepreisen gar nicht runter und
da geht es auch gar nicht nur um das
autofahren sondern alle energiepreise
sind gestiegen und da muss einfach etwas
neues her und das da können wir so nicht
weitermachen weil die belastung für
diese energiewende die wir uns leisten
die angeblich nur eine eiskugel uns alle
kosten soll also ich habe eine menge eis
auszugeben für einen haushalt mit vier
kindern und deswegen wünsche ich mir
etwas wo man sagt eine dauerhafte
entlastung ich möchte auch kein klima
geld oder irgend sowas weil das ist
wieder so eine umschichtung da darf ich
mich wieder anstellen und darf sagen ja
hier aber ich wollte ich möchte
insgesamt ja ich möchte dass wir das wir
senkung der energiepreise haben und ich
möchte gerne dass der staat ihnen gar
nicht so viel weg nimmt und dass ich
dann selber entscheide weil auch neun
euro ticket es ist ja alles schön und
gut aber eben ich bin auch eher im
ländlichen raum
bei uns bringt sozusagen an dass neun
euro ticket nicht viel es würde etwas
bringen wenn die busse doppelt so oft
fahren würden dann könnte man überlegen
irgendwie obmann umsteigt vom auto
irgendwie auf den öffentlichen
nahverkehr aber faktisch ist es ja
tatsächlich im ländlichen raum so dass
viele leute sagen das ist ja schön und
gut irgendwie dass das nur 9 euro kostet
aber ich komme halt nicht zur arbeit ich
kenne da komme ich zur schule und nicht
im verein und sie können also ich wohne
nicht im ländlichen raum aber selbst da
wird es schwierig für viele sachen dass
man sagt ohne auto kommen sie da
eigentlich nicht so recht ich persönlich
bin glücklich dass ich nicht so viel
fahren muss aber ich kenne viele also
pendler tun mir leid im moment und wenn
der weg zur arbeit quasi irgendwann
nicht mehr zu finanzieren wird und dann
kriegen bis 30 das müssen sie schon auch
also die haben ja eh fernpendler also
nicht ab dem ersten kilometer und gerne
was man natürlich auch an achsen muss um
mit also bei dieser ist ja in dieser
situation ist es ja so schnell zu
reagieren das ist auch ein problem der
bundesregierung das wirkt ab morgen ab
dem ersten juni andere länder spanien
italien frankreich
auch haben diese regelung teilweise ab
dem ersten februar ab dem ersten april
und das gleiche ist natürlich mit der
pendlerpauschale ich finde es gut und
fände es besser wenn es nicht ab dem 28
sondern ab dem ersten kilometer gelte
aber klar ist natürlich dass wirkt sich
bei der nächsten steuererklärung aus für
diejenigen die heute schon am monatsende
überlegen müssen wie sie über die runden
kommen hilft eine entlastung in einem
jahr nichts sondern die müssen schauen
wie sie das jetzt hinkriegen und das ist
natürlich insbesondere mit familien mit
mehreren kindern tatsächlich würde ich
mir gerne herrn werner reinholen wir
unsere debatte sie demonstrieren ja auch
eigentlich auch gegen autos wenn sie
sich auf die fahrbahn setzen was halten
sie denn jetzt eigentlich vom tank
rabatt oder sagen sie ist gut wenn wir
mal in der realität ankommen und alle
weniger auto fahren wir müssen auf jeden
fall gucken das natürlich müssen wir die
leute
insofern mitnehmen dass wir alle hier
gut und gut in dieser gesellschaft
zusammenleben können aber wir müssen
natürlich uns fragen wo sind was sind
die anreize die wir setzen und wir haben
den absoluten klima notfall und dann ist
es natürlich keine gute idee dann auch
noch ja es
dass noch mehr auto gefahren wird weil
natürlich geht es ja für alle sozusagen
und da wirklich sich mal wirklich zu
überlegen wollen wir diesen klima
notfall ernst nehmen als das besser ist
als diesen
lebensbedrohlichen notfall für unsere
ganze gesellschaft und dann wenn wir das
mal wirklich anerkannt haben und dass
ich auch mal wieder widerspiegeln würde
das indem wir die regierung zur
bevölkerung spricht und was sie für
maßnahmen einleiten dann würden wir auch
andere maßnahmen auch andere maßnahmen
ergreifen um das zu lösen